minecraft is a game in which you to
create your own world what did you do
it's an awesome game in which everyone
should play this part is simple I'm
creaking at this game and menu is like
some kind of secret garden
it looks like doom but why does it look
like a do how many motions aww what is
that it's a pig click on them ah oh my
god why yeah here ah this game is great
I love it
are they friends are they food like a
dummy likes following my mouth like that
mints I don't know how to get back down
survival mode is when you have to build
a shelter and protect yourself from the
creepers and zombies that come out at
nighttime you said I can build anything
when I build a 50 Cal and just when the
zombies come in just like chop them down
just keep chopping how long do you feel
the ha got Oakwood I'm getting wood huh
I suppose getting so dark good not have
night-vision goggles something's hurting
me they're sheep attack look like
bottleneck um you're losing light I
don't know what's hitting me ah yeah
you're gonna die no no to one okay I die
I play video games to like have sort of
escape time and this is making me to
work in creative mode you have unlimited
resources and you can fly okay here we
go
oh just quit 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 girls
I'm rich I'm not good till I say I'm
good
this is not logical yeah it's Minecraft
this just looks like a fitting room at
like Target or something don't judge my
house you can go super high up to find
it Oh
oh so beautiful so I tried minecraft for
the first time I went in with high hopes
of building a large sized square pizza
and I did not build that thing it's less
fun than call of duty but it's like I
definitely gets better for kids I
crafted mine crib hahahaha solid I came
in here today not knowing much about
Minecraft but I feel like I leave
knowing and absolutely nothing are we
gonna say an expert
concentrate